you keep saying that well because in
certain States the positive civil law uh
has a license for abortion that
therefore it's legal and there's no
moral conundrum here but what I'm
pointing out is that sometimes the
positive civil law is unjust compared to
the objective moral law this is
something like Martin Luther King talk
about a lot that's again you can't you
can't say that it's well I mean you can
say that it's wrong according to the
objective moral law but according to my
objective moral law there is it's not
wrong I just think I think your if there
is a distinction between your moral law
and my moral law then there can't be an
objective moral law